we are going to be discussing again
that's quite topical at this moment
because of the premiere film release
called past on palm sacrifice not past
my pawn sacrifice pardon me I went into
the movie with trepidation because I was
very very fearful that Hollywood would
portray Bobby as an idiot savant
obsessed with chess but has no other
redeeming social virtues or values you
know the type of person couldn't tie a
shoe and this kinds of things well
fortunately that wasn't the case it was
a great storyline of course Bobby
Fischer has a very very compelling story
and it was really really well acted by
the Tobey Maguire who played the lead
role of course I can't remember the
Boris Spassky figure but I yeah I
thought that they did a really good job
however so on a scale of one to ten I'd
give it a seven I really would however
then this is really really really really
irks him the producer directors people
had come out and said you know like we
hired a chess person to be as authentic
to true life as possible to you know to
keep the facts straight and so forth and
so on and yet they didn't they took
dramatic license if you will there was
one scene in the movie from this game
game 1 and if you ask a lot of people
about Bobby Fischer they may not know
too much about him but it seems like
everybody remembers Bishop takes H 2 and
I remember watching the ABC Wide World
of Sports Show it's a it's a small clip
where first of all everybody
wanted to know was bobby fisher' going
to play would he make it to Iceland and
all of these things and he missed the
opening ceremony the game had started
and there was still no Bobby Fischer and
then finally he came I'm going to say
ten minutes late his clock had been
started it he sat down he shook hands he
filled out a score sheet and then he
very carefully arranged all of his
pieces and then he reached for his night
on g8 and somehow in midair
adjusted it so that the night's head was
turning to the left and he set it down
comfortably on the f6 square here these
very very large hands and it was almost
a kind of a ballet that he did with his
pieces and that was his first move
Knight f6 in EA the match was underway
when you think about their rivalry
before the World Championship Boris had
a huge edge they had played five
tournament games Boris won 3-2 draws
Boris had never ever lost a Bobby
Fischer bobby had this great run through
the inner zonals and the candidates and
he came as the overwhelming ratings
favorite and they played game 1 in the
movie when Bobby makes the fateful
decision of capturing the pawn on h2 the
character Boris Spassky in the movies
makes his move g3 says Robert James you
don't look so well and then Tobey
Maguire resigns that didn't happen that
didn't happen at all let's see in truth
what did happen first of all I bore Asit
open with the Queen pond Boris was one
of the first world champions who besides
being a really fantastic human being by
the way he was a universal player
he could play both d4 and e4 prior to
Boris Spassky you had players like
Michael Botvinnik
Emmanuel Lasker kappa blanka who were
much more narrow in their opening
repertoire and preferring one efore or
one d for more or less exclusively and i
really thought of boris spassky is the
first really universal world champion
today we have magnus carlsen who's
absolutely amazing
he literally plays so many openings as
white so many defenses by as black it's
remarkable that he can score so well in
openings that he may not have as deep
knowledge as others do Knight f6 c4 e6
Knight f3 d5 Knight c3 Bishop b4 the
veresov today I must say that this line
has actually become increasingly popular
this defense bishop before e3 was a
Boris passkeys choice today the sharpest
variations are considered Bishop g5 d
takes e4 e for a lot of lot of games in
this vienna and also as well pardon me
Bishop g5 Bishop g5 army h6 Bishop
Bishop h4 g5 Bishop here Knight e4 with
the idea of playing c5 and Queen a5 a
lot of very sharp modern modern-day
lines
Spassky reverts to the tried-and-true
rubenstein nimzo-indian defense if you
will and played the movie three castles
Bishop d3 see five castles knight c6 so
today ah I would say my goodness a
thousand games have been played not even
from this starting position there's a
lot of other as a long long line of
theory for this entire variation and top
grandmasters are willing to play either
side black or white of this opening a2
a3 and Bishop a5 today that move is not
considered as popular as Bishop takes c3
B takes c3 takes on c4 takes on c4 b6 as
well as Queen c7 in this variation a lot
of times black is aspiring to play the
move e5 in order to bring out his Bishop
on its natural diagonal that was not
Bobby's choice Bobby played after a3
Bishop a5 so here is actually a crucial
moment for Boris and Boris played in the
game 92 and I think after 92 black is
basically just fine
I think the crucial line of play is C
takes d5 e takes d5 takes on c5 because
of the threat now of b4 simply winning
upon black is obliged to go for Bishop
takes c3 B takes c3 Bishop g4 and he's
going to try to round up this pawn one
day with a move like Queen a5
but it's not going to be that easy and
after c4 you can see that what white
wants to do is put this Bishop on this
diagonal and I consider White's position
favourable yeah none of that happened as
Boris played the move Knight eetu and
now after takes
and Bishop back we soon it starts to
look like a Queens gambit accepted where
the Queens come off the board so just
around these parts people were already
if you will shocking the game up as a
draw because the pawn structures four
versus four two versus two white at this
exact moment only has a small lead in
development and a little bit freer
pieces but all of the let us say
business squares on the d8 the D file
pardon me are protected so draw was
predicted Bishop b2 Bishop d7 small
tactic black cannot play Bishop takes f6
Bishop takes f6 and pick up a piece
because oopsy-daisy the rook on a1 is
hanging so rook AC one look F eighty
eight ninety four so now again we're
seeing a more more of the wood coming
off the game is getting increasingly
balanced now we were expecting that who
would be the first to blink so to speak
who would be the first to offer or draw
as we can see the positions incredibly
tame equal equal equal you can't point
to any single sector of the board and
say either side has an edge both sides
begin to bring their King into play and
Knight e4 Bobby actually makes the first
concrete threat in the game with the
mood rook C to check being threatened
Brooks e1 offering a trade of rooks the
rooks were traded and f6 Knight a5 96
King up Bishop back get rid of that
Knight Bishop up take stakes and be five
and here we have it probably the single
most famous moment in World Championship
match history as so many Americans who
just have a little interest in chess are
aware of this fateful decision now in
the movie they really show this moment
as one of great perturbance for Bobby
Orr Tobey Maguire that Bobby was being
affected by the cameras on the stage so
you think of those old movies you go to
a movie and you hear that rolling film
tape
so Bobby complained to the arbiter that
his concentration was being disturbed by
the film cameras and could they do
something to moderate the noise and lo
thermit promised to do that but in the
movie it was sort of like you know after
the complaint he comes back and you know
impulsively captures the pawn know that
what happened was he had actually sat
down at the board and Boris was at the
board and Bobby popped out with this
move Bishop takes h2 and Boris literally
you know jump back in a seat from a
seating position he was you know visibly
shocked by this in the movie they have
Boris coming back from a walk sitting
down and then asking Bobby if that he
was he looked unwell after g-3 Boris
never said anything of the sort to Bobby
so it's very very clear and obvious that
the bishop is trapped on h2 and that
thanks to these two pawns White's King
is simply going to walk over here
and capture the bishop Bobby of course
had seen that and he immediately played
h5 with a very obvious intention of
playing h4g takes h4 and being able to
retreat his Bishop back he certainly saw
the move king e to h4 King f3 and now
what Bobby's mentally ahead in in mind
what he and his intended line of play
was to play the move h3 so that this
prevents white from playing the move
king g2 trapping the bishop if it's
black to move black would be winning
with a move Bishop G 1 followed by h2
and then the bishop can never be
captured in the King would be stuck
protecting upon from promotion so h3
King here Bishop here King takes Bishop
takes was Bobby's main line and he
thought okay well now my bishop is
getting ready to escape and blah blah
blah
and of course the move he missed was
Bishop d2 oops and the next move is King
g2 and King takes bishop and so on okay
so when when Boris play g3 h5 kingi to
Bobby now had an epiphany and awakening
he realized oh dear his intended
variation falls to Bishop to d2 King e7
kingi - takes --tags --tags --tags
King here King 2d6
a 4 and now King to defy bishop a 3 oh
hold on just a second do I had I'm
putting it on training but yeah okay
a for King to d5 Bishop to a3 and now
this is the crucial moment right here
so Bobby everybody remembers that Bobby
lost the game by getting his Bishop trap
the remarkable thing is that he could
have still saved the position that this
is where his actual blunder in the game
was he played the move King efore double
question mark losing okay he wasn't in
time trouble or anything like that that
was moved 37 clearly what black will
pardon me clearly what black wants to do
is to raid these three pawns for that
one pump he wants to trade this pawn for
that pawn and then he wants to go King
here and round up the pawn Julia
yet well that that that would be great
as well just to get the wrong color rook
pawn so here Bobby had the clear drawing
line and it went a six okay there is a
lot of false leads one false lead that's
very attractive is to go King C for why
not why not just go here and pick up all
of these pawns but this was this one
would actually lose
and this bishop basically does a good
enough job at stopping these pawns that
you're in time to eat this and white
ends up winning by the way analysis by
Yan Tim on the guy who we saw previously
earlier today
okay so King here Bishop here so the
correct drawing line is to play a six
okay now this is White's best chance of
winning was to play B six King here fa5
king back and I think it was here this
was the this was the idea that Bobby had
missed if you take all of these pawns
here off the board and it's just these
four pawns you stick the King on a eight
it's a fortress
thanks to stalemate so you wanted to
learn White's pawns to be six and a five
and get that fortress so your idea very
much is to play F or F I pardon me g6e
five and f4 and to make sure you trade
and then just scurry back with your King
let's see how did it go that didn't
happen so this happened in the game so
king came to d5 and then this very bad
move kingi for Grandmaster ludica
pokémon by the way very very interesting
man from Czechoslovakia who was he was a
wonderful agitator so in those days of
Czechoslovakia year you were almost
required to read Marxist doctrine and
unfortunately for the authorities
ludecke had a photographic memory and
when you got all of the soviet
kind of manuals about mmm
cold social culture norms economy and
things like that many of them were
contradictory many something that you
would find in Volume one went against
something you'd find a volume three so
he would go to all these political
rallies and the guy would be up there
shouting about the socialist paradise
and everything like this and then ludic
would say yes but on page 16 on volume 7
you have said this at this visit this
which contradicts everything you've just
said and the guy would turn red face and
ludecke and arrested this was a constant
in his life by the way it was very very
very funny he wrote a book checkmate in
Prague about his experiences in prisons
extensive understanding of the prison
system of Czechoslovakia kingi for
Bishop c5 a6 b6 f v king came to g5 and
now f4 i think this is he takes f4 King
takes f4 King H I think hold on I
believe it was Boris Spassky who sealed
his move e5 takes f4 yeah I just have to
check the historical so there jerk and
Bobby's going back to the home that he
lived he okay the the match took place
in rec avec the capital city and largest
city in Iceland but he didn't stay in
the city proper he had a his own home so
he would be away from the media and the
press and he could repair so he had a
bodyguard driver
man from the Icelandic police force a me
who he became very close friends with
who was driving and Bill Lombardi in the
car and Bobby is you know moaning ah why
did I play Bishop h2 why did I play
Bishop h2 and Bill explains to him that
that wasn't the losing move ooh
Bobby is like what I and he showed Bobby
he had those Argentine chess sets sets
he showed Bobby how he could have made a
draw and Bobby's like I'm such an idiot
an idiot you know and that would have
been great for the whole dramatic effect
of the movie the real version as opposed
to what they actually did so he takes f4
King takes f4 I think this was obviously
the sealed move king came to h5 and the
whole problem is that black is going to
get out temp owed and eventually White's
King is just going to pick up all the
pawns so you can see how far Bobby
played it out okay
so up to this moment because I was just
a kid of course is I thought that Bobby
still had chances to draw you know I'm
thinking oh my gosh you know all you got
to do is push that pawn make a queen the
bishop has to come back you sacrifice
the pawn you take the pawn I thought
that Bobby was going to make a draw
unfortunately just about the time that I
thought it was a draw Bobby exactly
though okay so the problem of course is
white King gets to c7 protects the pawn
blacks King will have to retreat to a
six so for example the final moves of
the
might be something like here here here
here here and now you have to give up
this b7 pawn and it's draw if you take
this King and flip it to the a8 square
it's a draw it's amazing
so let's just see if what I say is true
let's just see that I just have to do
this for purposes
okay so now you can see that the King
here there's no way that white King can
approach these two squares King here
King hared stalemate and this would have
been a draw
we were trying at the chess coffee shop
that I that I frequented in Seattle the
last exit we would go over the reports
right the newspaper and we were trying
in the adjournment to get to such a
position and we thought that Bobby could
save it but it was lost at the
adjournment any questions any questions
I'll just tell you a few things Bobby
Fischer of course in 1972 was arguably
the biggest celebrity in the world
Muhammad Ali hadn't yet really become
Muhammad Ali he he was very very well
known of course but bobby was like known
throughout the world and we expected
that bobby was going Bobby had said that
all he ever wanted to do was play chess
and that when he became the world
champion he would be an active world
champion so we had all expected Bobby to
kind of lead a parade of a new era in
chess and I had a very dear friend his
name was Emmett Watson mr. Emmett was
kind of this curmudgeonly old
journalist from Seattle who who had
created a society for lesser Seattle so
he wanted everybody to move away from
Seattle so he had gotten t-shirts in
Seattle we don't tan we rust yeah leave
Seattle go away from Seattle and Emmett
called me up and said yes come on down
for dinner
I go where are we meeting blah blah blah
so I go to
to the Olympic Hotel in downtown Seattle
and much of my surprise we went into a
restaurant where the like this this
whole room was reserved for this amazing
table of 40 persons and I said to Emmett
like gee I thought we were having dinner
and he said we are sit down so all of
these gentlemen none of whom might ever
met my life we began to have you know
three course for course by of course
dinner and at the end at the very end
guy taps his glass and he says well
welcome again everybody to Sports
Illustrated annual get-together with all
of our had heads of all of the offices
of Sports Illustrated from all over the
world and he turns to me and he says yes
like whatever happened to Bobby Fischer
and I mumble some apology and non-answer
and he said well the reason is is in
1973 we had a dinner just like this what
we're holding now and all of our editors
from around the world were trying to
understand how we were going to explain
to our subscribers that the sports
superstars of today or chess
grandmasters and we didn't want to lose
our readership by equating chess as a
sport but we expected you know
million-dollar events million dollar
tournaments so whatever happened to
Bobby Fischer and I went really
you know like ah you know it would have
been great and I can tell you that on
many occasions there was like almost
this
this incredibly powerful hope that bobby
would play for our Olympic team how cool
that would be that he would come back
and play on our Olympic team or visit a
US Championship or visit a tournament
and there was Bobby sightings everywhere
like everybody said oh I saw Bobby at
the Pasadena Public Library or Bobby
visited I remember Bobby Fischer in like
1974 visited the America was it 74 73
I'm not sure visited American Open and
literally you cannot get the chess
players to leave their boards while
their clock is ticking
even on a four alarm fire yeah you know
like they're still thinking I got to
save my bishop you know got to got to do
something but literally the whole
tournament hall emptied out because the
rumor was Bobby Fischer was there and
everybody wanted to go and get a picture
with Bobby I'll tell you one last story
Bobby that I really thought was
fantastic was 1980 and the gentleman's
name was Arne freed Pavao arm freed
Pavel was a German industrialist who had
made a fortune in cement and he decided
that he wanted to sponsor a chess club
in Holland
called the Koenig's Club the Kings Club
and he wanted it to be the champion of
Holland so he got it in his mind that he
wanted Bobby Fischer as an honored
member of the conics Club so he called
up Claudia the Secretary of Bobby
Fischer and said can I arrange a meeting
with Bobby Fischer yes you can but
there's a $5,000 fee for meeting with
Bobby Fischer no problem said arm freed
and he came to Pasadena and they met in
a restaurant and arm freed said well
this is my business I would like to
invite you too
come to Holland and play for my club
one game I'll pay $100,000 cash you play
one game we you know it's first-class
treatment all the way Hotel travel food
everything you stay a night or two as
your wish you travel back at that moment
the Koenig's club it's sort of like
there's the master class then there's an
expert's class and then there's other
classes the Koenig's Club was literally
on level one okay so Bobby said who will
be my opponent and arm freed said well
I'm not sure that I suspect the player
will be about 1200 okay
so Bobby this is really a very very weak
amateur player and Bobby all this is
really great this is very good good good
let me think about it let's meet again
tomorrow at the specific place in this
park in Pasadena
so our agreed set fine so they meet in
the specific place in Penn Park they
talk take these long box they have this
wonderful dinner and Bobby keeps asking
him questions that aren't free just
wasn't prepared for for example will
there be a gate a gate you know tickets
for sale for the spectators no it's just
the club to get together there's a one
meeting the clubs and there's no gate
it's free okay will it be videotaping
videotaping no I hope the TV will come
for one or two three minutes that they
will be on the nightly news but no we're
not videotaping them will there be any
posters posters what do you mean what's
a poster well you know you take my
picture you put it up on the wall you
sell the poster for 20 bucks no you're
just coming to play a game and this goes
on and on and on so two days passed
and Bobby keeps asking these questions
that just aren't aren't here here's the
money would you please come to my club
employee and it comes in two aren't
reads mind that Bobby for whatever
reason is going to say no like this is
just an easy layup come and play an
exhibition game go home and I can use
your name that Bobby Fischer is a member
of the Koenig's called Chess Club and an
arm freed realizes that my God if he
goes home tomorrow back to Amsterdam
he's going to have no proof that he ever
even met with Bobby Fischer Bobby's
going to say no and that's it so he
decides to hire a private investigator
to take a photo of the two of them
together from afar okay so that at least
he'll have proof that he can show his
family I met Bobby Fischer
so the third day he was going to meet
Bobby in the park in Pasadena at the
specific place at noon and armed Fried's
there but there's no Bobby Bobby was
actually quite punctual in such meetings
and this was very surprising for armed
free armed Creed's in a suit and tie
looking very proper sits on the bench 10
15 minutes goes by still no Bobby
Fischer
now he's getting worried that maybe he's
in the wrong part of the park pretty
sure he's got it right but he's still
concerned when suddenly visits and he
looks around and behind the trees Bobby
Fischer's hiding behind it Bobby what
are you doing in there come on out no
you come on in so hard three comes in
he's clay under the brushes you know and
what's going on Bobby says there's a man
he's trying he's following me
and it suddenly occurs to aren't free
that in truth Bobby had spotted the club
I get tickets picture and it scared into
death but he was being followed
many many many wonderful stories of
Bobby one more that I desperately do
like to share know he declined $100,000
there was this one I really really liked
a lot so in the days of the GM a 1987 88
89 Bobby Fischer was very interested in
what the grandmasters union was trying
to do and he had contacted mr. Bessel
[ __ ] the chairman of the GM a and said
could he come to Brussels and blah blah
blah so Bessel brought Bobby over and
Bobby didn't want to stay at the hotel
he because he was afraid he'd be
recognized right you know like the bad
bad media people would see him and of
course since Brussels was the head of
NATO you know you got me T up the u era
after ying-yang he wanted to stay in
Bethel's home private home and vessels
fine but Bobby didn't want to go
anywhere Bobby who didn't want to go to
restaurants for dinner like let's order
the food and bring the food here so
Bobby was really really secluded in
vessels home and is getting more and
more more frustrating for vessel because
he really wants to show him the beauty
of Brussels and Belgium
Bobby is refusing so a week goes by and
then totally unexpected Bobby says let's
go to a bar what says Bell I mean like
sure any kind of oh yeah a bar where
there's lots of girls lots of women
well said Bessel I happen to know one or
two let's go to this bar so they go to a
bar and instantly two women come over
and ask them that they want company and
would they buy them a glass of champagne
and Bessel's happy to do this so vessels
got is back to Bobby and vessels talking
to the woman and that he's really
hearing Bobby's conversation back here
and the conversation goes something like
and so what do you do for a living and
Bobby says I am the world chess champion
and the lady says okay come on seriously
yesterday it was Dolly the day I got the
world chess champion if you're the world
chess champion what's your name
and she goes Robert James Fisher I'm
known as Bobby Fischer the woman says I
know that name I know who you are I
still don't believe you're Bobby Fischer
show me proof
Bobby had spent the last 10 15 years
hiding his identity now he's in a
situation where he wants to prove that
he really is the world chess champion
and he has nothing no driver's license
nothing that says Bobby Fischer watches
and no business card or anything like
this so the so vessel by this time is
turned around and is vouching for him
yeah he's really Huy says he is the
girls look at one another they look at
the two gentlemen and say okay we
believe you just buy us another glass of
champagne with that was the wonderful
frustrating story of Bobby Fischer for
years denying who he was the moment he
wanted you know proper vindication valid
validation of who he was he didn't
happen I just thought that was hilarious
mix anyway I recommend the movie it's a
good movie see it upon sacrifice and
just like me try your best to overlook
the historical inaccuracies and you'll
have a good time thank you